à l'étranger madonna sort de londres
cette fois la chanteuse a choisi de ne
plus cacher mais de réagir la pop star
est depuis quelques semaines au coeur
d'une polémique autour de l'adoption
d'un jeune enfant au malawi
on a très vite parler de passe droit la
réaction du père de l'enfant avait
troublé l'opinion publique
madonna se défend elle répond aux
attaques dans une interview retour sur
la faire avec stéphane breitner david 13
mois est arrivé à londres comme une star
caché sous un vêtement entouré de
policiers est traqué par la presse
encore une fois dix et ont une vedette
richissime madonna en l'occurrence
venait de suivre la mode de l'adoption
d'un enfant miséreux
depuis la chanteuse est sous le feu des
critiques en angleterre mais également
au malawi où l'enfant est né madonna est
allé le chercher dans l'un des
orphelinats qu'elle finance il ya trois
semaines
à l'époque le père de david disait
l'avoir abandonnée maintenant il parle
d'enlèvement
alors hier la star a choisi de
télévision pour se défendre et qu'on la
laisse est à l'orphelinat on m'a dit
qu'aucun membre de sa famille ne lui
avait rendu visite
c'est la raison pour laquelle je me suis
intéressé à david c'est quelqu'un
m'avait dit son père vient le voir
toutes les semaines où sa grand-mère lui
rend visite régulièrement et s'en occupe
bien je n'aurais pu penser à lui
certains parlent de passe-droit dont
aurait bénéficié madonna pour adopter un
étranger doit séjourner au moins un an
et demi au malawi la chanteuse ni rester
cuit jour malgré cela elle a obtenu la
garde de l'enfant pour 18 mois et s'est
dit à son père que je serais heureuse de
ramener la vie dans son village que
j'étais prête à l'aider financièrement
pour son éducation mais il m'a dit non
c'est non
l'afer a pris une tournure judiciaire au
malawi des associations humanitaires ont
déposé un recours pour annuler la
procédure d'adoption
jugement le 17 novembre